right now the ones you got on see she
wanted no no look at them no no down the
box is gone right now oh no no no
i'll flip this fridge i'll flip this
[ __ ] fridge
she knows you've gone for a [ __ ] today
no pull down your boxes right [ __ ]
now and just tell me and tell me tell me
you know how to wipe your ass you fat
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's all right
yeah
[Music]
guys what's up girls what's up
[Music]
um
what's going on guys it's monday fun day
once again you're chilling with your
boys jay money fire loft waves
if you like the smooth mellow tones that
are smacking you in your eardrum as we
speak yeah we're talking to you spotify
listeners
apple podcast listeners
please leave your boys a nice review
five stars would be great but just be
honest say it with chest feel how you
feel it's all good it's all love it does
wonders for the show
it increases the reach it allows us to
to start laying bricks in this cabin in
the woods this cult that we're trying to
form the white robes and yeezys don't
come cheap guys so please help the show
tell a friend to tell a friend leave a
review um guys over on youtube chirp
sitting in the comments we're gonna need
the breeders guys we're gonna need the
breeders and the feeders so chirp
sitting in the comments uh build some
relationships
and uh like and subscribe to the channel
uh por favor um and lastly guys if you
enjoy the episodes that you're watching
stroke listening to now and you want a
little bit more
every thursday there's an episode
waiting for you all you need to do is
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs just pause the
episode right now head on over there
that's one more time patreon
dot com forward slash shits and gigs
you've got over two years worth of
content on there guys two years worth of
content to catch up on you've got an
episode that's going to come out every
single thursday without fail um we're
going to start doing a live show soon so
if you want first dibs
uh on tickets you got patreon if you
like our merch and you want a little bit
of a discount you got patreon if you
want to see what we're like in real life
and you want to catch up with resume
call patreon guys so um
i'm also thinking about setting up a
discord on there that i'll talk to you
about later oh um
but yeah patreon so it's three pound a
month tempe a day get on over there and
enjoy yourself patreon.com force our
shits and gigs guys thank you very very
very
very
much you know the deal guys um
before you do your fun fact real quick
i've got two movie recommendations oh
two quick moves okay okay i thought let
me do this again because i don't want to
get into it too yeah okay
real quick first one i watched was on
netflix the other day it's called
boiling point i've heard about it
i feel like it resonate with you yeah
it's the the kitchen one yeah
who the [ __ ] told me about that last
week someone told me about that last
week said it's really good it is good
yes i've got to watch it
i don't know i don't think there's any
music for the whole thing now that i'm
thinking about it it might be like no
one country of old mentor yeah yeah i
could be completely wrong but in the in
my head i don't remember hearing music
okay um a fam it's intense okay it's
intense
it just follows that basically it
follows a head chef who's just opened a
new restaurant with a partner um she's
like she also
like runs the
like front of house and it's uh it's a
buff restaurant and it's just
the vast majority of it just seems like
everyday [ __ ]
but fam like
it seems too stressful to manage it just
seems too stressful bro like one person
i won't spoil it but
yeah it's a good movie okay i've
thoroughly enjoyed it okay cool i'll add
that to the list um and he's got his own
life traumas that kind of enter into
that mix as well it's just like i'm not
working in the kitchen that's the bottom
line okay i'm not working in a
restaurant i'm not working in a kitchen
okay because there's just levels of
abuse in there that i'm just not willing
to tolerate
men get abused in the kids
it's not personal that's the thing yeah
it is never personal i can't separate
that i know
the way they speak to each other i can't
separate yeah i'm sorry i just can't
um and the other second one people are
going to think i'm a [ __ ] for saying
this
trolls world tour
foo hat
people are sleeping on trolls trolls
world tour nah
rose world tour
is the best trolls movie
i've not seen a trolls music in a trolls
movie i just literally just said that
trolls is all right you know as a brand
it's good
trolls world tour
there's bangers in there
yeah oh yes like sing two just like sing
two
just like singing you're hilarious bro
you think it's a joke it's on netflix
watch it tonight bro you've got the time
trolls world tour yeah oh it's slack
okay it's slaps bro
because i tell you what it focuses on
different uh it's hard because you
haven't seen any trolls yeah but trolls
is all about music these men vibe from
music okay and the main trolls colony
you learn in this movie that they're
it's all about they're all about um pop
music okay it's not something that you'd
notice from through the other two trolls
okay okay okay but this is focused on
about like oh it turns out it's just our
village that's based on um pop okay and
they're learning that there are other
troll villages that are all focused on
different types of music okay so there's
a rock village yeah there's the pop
village there's a funk village yeah and
anderson pack has a character in in the
funk village and he has a prize he put
he he writes a song for that okay bangs
okay it bangs okay it's called it's all
love i played it today in the shower
that's how much the sun banks um
um
today in the shower bro
there's a classical village
and there's um what else there's a
techno village as well okay and then
outside of the villages there's little
like little sporadic little people that
have their own niches there's a k-pop
little niche and there's a reggaeton
little niche okay
and uh there's also a yodeling one
and
you know wow the reggaeton and the k-pop
slap yeah the [ __ ] techno yeah
oh my days bro the techno one there's um
there's an opening scene the opening
scene is in the techno village and
they're playing uh one more time
and the whole village is vibing yeah and
then there's um there's the
the ram just hear me out all right the
king of that village
he's um the dj
and it's hardest because you ever see
trolls but like everything in trolls in
the trolls world is alive so the flowers
are alive the buildings are alive the
transportation is alive like they're all
living things
um and like on his deck there's a button
which is like the drop
and the button is like
hit me hit me hit me
and the the king's like wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
it's like
everyone's vibing five minutes
[Music]
it goes let's go back he smacks it and
it's like and the whole this massive
wave comes out of the deck and so one
more
it is sick it just gives you well the
whole movie gives you appreciation for
different styles of music that you
typically don't listen to okay i don't
really listen to dance music and stuff
but when that one scene you're like that
song's actually a banger i hear that
it's actually a banger i hear that and
like the funk village they're they're
all about like 80s funks 70s
that's what they're all about i can
imagine and you just
i can imagine and see even with a pop
some of the songs that they come up with
they're like that's actually a [ __ ]
banger like that's the thing about
that's the same with sing same was
saying and trolls they have this habit
of like
reenacting songs
that you're like ra
like i haven't thought about
this and you get invested as to why like
because they're trying to sell you that
their style of music is the one yeah and
it's just like [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] that's a genre fair [ __ ] there's a
show i can i can see the appeal of it i
spank i can see the appeal expect you
have to watch it on like a very lazy
sunday where i don't care about like
psychological thrillers yeah yeah i'm
not i'm just poor inside i'm just
putting something on to enjoy yeah
trolls world tour is a movie if you had
honest to god i'm not even asking you to
watch the first two
do i need to watch the first no you
don't you actually don't just understand
that it's just a happy-go-lucky film
okay trolls world tour fab say listen
it's a movie
it's a movie
it's good [ __ ] okay um anyway fun fact i
ain't knocking it out bro let's go all
right say let's say this
um oh okay
in a village in the dominican republic
around 1 in 50 children are born with a
rare condition where they appear female
at birth and are raised as girls but
then develop male genitalia when they
hit puberty
i could be pronouncing this wrong but
they are known as hueve duchess which
roughly translates to penis at 12.
that's fascinating that's one of the
most fascinating facts i've read that
i've read before reading on this show
one in 50 one in 50 solely in the
dominican republic that when they hit
puberty they just get a dick yep but
you'd never know that they but they have
a they actually born with a vagina look
at the kids how they look
they're like
little bow wow-esque
i was gonna say are these are these two
twins
are they just random use i don't know
brother
rare condition where they feel a pure
female what do you mean
are they female or
not yeah they appear people like today
their balls literally drop at 12. so
this girl was oh no this guy this kid
here appeared female
wow
one in 50 that's high that's high
that's very high i've never heard of
this never bro never ever heard of it
that's fascinating
i actually went on
uh google i've found i went on wikipedia
to even search the
definition of
a deutsches or like the if there was
more context on it
um
and he said obviously whoever duchess is
a term used in dominican republic for
children with a specific type of
intersexuality
um they appear as or they're classified
as girls until and when they're born due
to physical features by around 12 like i
said the male genitalia drops it says
this is due to a deficiency in the
production of the 5a reductase which is
an enzyme involved in metabolism or of
testosterone
so that's why they they don't have as
much
the five times five eight testing so
they hit 12. and the 5a just rolls
through it rolls through and the same
the same phenomenon occurs in papua new
guinea where it's called
kualu
obviously that's that's in their
language don't know what it loosely
translates to the same thing
um which suggests the person is
transforming into a male thing
yeah that is wild what apparently
happens in turkey as well
can you imagine thinking you're a girl
your whole life and then randomly yeah
literally at 12 you're like nah you're a
guy you know ah
that is actually mad
still i don't need that kind of stress
at 12. i'm mad bro
because that's that's prime time i see a
seven yeah you're seven year eight yeah
i don't need you do you think i need
that in year seven
bullying
i started the semester as a girl and now
i'm a guy yeah that the not even the
teachers would understand wagua to be
fair one in 50 they probably will oh
yeah true true one if there's bear these
man in here
true one if that's high that's very high
what aren't they eating
what aren't they eating or is dominican
republic so small that it's just an
incest thing now
and this this thing just repeats let me
check the population of dominican oh
it's gonna be small i'm gonna guess
something as small as
300 000 oh no you're you're far off bro
too low way too low
well not because
jamaica's population is only like
3 million i said according to wikipedia
that 2018 estimate obviously this is a
bit old
was
just under 11 million that's impossible
dominican republic well i'm not arguing
with you
i'm not saying that it's a jamaican one
for me please bro
yeah uh hold on uh and the federalized
population by approximately 10.8 million
yeah of which of whom 3.3 live in the
santo dominico capital city yeah
yeah
uh jamaica's population right yeah
they're gonna tell me 30 million or some
[ __ ] no i can never be
well jamaica's got the biggest
population out of all the caribbean
islands i'm certain of it
nope um
2.7 so i'm saying i knew it was three
million 2.7 dominican republic
has like four times as much yeah
according to this thing bro
that doesn't make no sense fam that's
what you're saying
i've got my geography all mixed up which
makes perfect sense because who gives a
[ __ ] at the end of the day who actually
cares
but wow okay i didn't know that yeah
right would i i don't have an answer for
them then
that's 1 in 50 bro
that's a wild that's at least one person
that everyone knows yeah right
rags every at least one person knows
that at least one person
dominican republic knows someone who has
that
who suffers from
yeah you're you're
wow you little duchess
you're a little duchess
nah that's bullying that is bullying
yeah you're a little duchess that's what
i'm saying yes seven couldn't handle it
i couldn't handle it nah guess what what
fuegs is a duchess
what do you mean what'd you mean man's a
duchess he just rolled into the the male
changing rooms today i've seen him in
his dutchess
you can never tell me he's not
yo you want to maybe he's a duchess yo
that's a lot for any human being to
handle because last week he was he was
listening up derek
and now he just refuses to admit yeah
[Laughter]
me and derek are the same children
him and derek are boys now oh we're just
gonna have to get on with it oh my dave
i wonder what they're um
because i'm assuming with that kind of
like with that kind of like uh how do i
say it
that kind of culture
because that's obviously 150 is huge
like that's integral to their culture
now they just understand that as a thing
i wonder what their perception of
obviously because you see how like
uh like transgender topics are just like
open discussion yes
and just like it's a learning like
transgender as a as a whole
um
or the discussion of of yeah trans trent
like
trans whatever you want to call it
it's a very new discussion
like in the west
and i wonder like people you'd think
people from the dominican republic must
have like a very
laissez-faire view on it it's just like
it's a normality of it
it's just normality over there so i
wonder if they kind of look at like the
struggles that people are having in
america because they're probably very
close to america i'm sure i wonder if
they're looking over there like i don't
understand
what the big deal is yeah
like if they want to be a woman be a
woman like we have that every three days
yeah
like i don't understand what the issue
is but yeah that's that's fascinating to
me i wonder if they could bring
a sign of perspective
as to what it's like in general
day-to-day culture because at the minute
like it's very like trans culture is
very like
for lack of a better word it's very
shove down your throat
in terms of like
you don't have time
like the as far as i'm concerned right
to be fair this is this is from an
outside perspective because i
i haven't experienced this in my
day-to-day life like i haven't had many
interactions with trans people for them
or for
activists who want to push like
a trans narrative on to me for me to
even have a discussion about it but
from what i've seen in the media it
seems like a very like
this is what it is
we haven't got time to hear your
thoughts on it
but just hold the information hold the
information this is what's happening
yeah yeah yeah yeah deal with it yeah
and if you ask me any questions
like you're against us yeah just be
ready for the backlash yeah yeah oh yeah
we haven't got time for questions
this is how it is
i'm gonna run up in your toilet and
you're gonna see me in there
do you understand me yeah yeah i'm gonna
run up in your toilet and you're gonna
see me in there and i don't have to tell
you
i'm trying to lips
i don't need to tell you anything
if you're attracted to women i'm a woman
i don't need to tell you [ __ ]
deal with it yeah if you wanted to know
that's on you yeah yeah you were gonna
know when i was ready to tell you
because i need to feel safe
um
and i wonder if maybe potentially people
from i know it happens at a very young
age so it is different but i wonder if
people who have been dealing with it for
more generations
could potentially bring a more
light-hearted view
to the the open discussion of what's
okay what's not okay
this should happen should this happen
um or
because of very much like i feel like at
the minute is
every like anything goes wherever the
lgbtq community decides
it's gonna run
and then we just have to run with it
otherwise you're you're against
progress
so i wonder potentially if they could
bring something to the table and be like
oh this is how we do it this is just how
we do it it's how we've always done it
and it seems to work fine no one has any
issue
to the point where people could be like
oh ra
that makes sense i hear that i do hear
that
but
dude i have no butts i just hear it i
have no bites either but because it's
all hypothetical yeah yeah it's
literally all right
i'm just [ __ ] speaking out loud
thinking out loud sorry
yeah it's a different thing completely
like that's that's something i was never
even privy to or oblivious to prior to
reading that i didn't even think that
existed do you think that's mad though
in the world that we live in now
and how fast easy access information is
yeah or how easy to access information
is
i think it's bonkers that
that can be a thing
in an english-speaking country spanish
that we had no idea was existed no
comprehension
not one single comprehension one in 50.
that's a lot of man
that's a lot of people brother what did
you i'll tell you exactly how many
people it is how what did you say 11
million just shy of 11.
let's quote 10. 10
10 million divided by 50.
that's what would be right
it'll be one divided by 50 times thingy
times a million yeah no time
yeah you sure yeah all right cool sorry
1 divided by 50 divided by 50
times 10 million times 10
oh it's 200 000 people it's a lot of
people
that's 200 000 people
that's a lot of [ __ ] people
wow
damn
damn
i knew my algorithm was correct it was
still i did my weight divided by i knew
you were 2000 yeah yeah
i was kicking away i knew i was thinking
i'm not done
divided by 50. yeah tell me your
dividend is the same myself yeah fair
enough all right cool but yeah that's
wild 200 000 people that's a lot of
people man [ __ ]
in a country much smaller than ours one
sixth the side of ours wow man
wow
wow
never mind okay
guys we're gonna take a very quick break
to send some love over to the boys at
man escaped so guys real quick man to
man
have you started spring cleaning yet
we're in april now have you started the
spring cleaning real question man to man
off camera
off the books come on off the records
yeah have you started are the carpets do
the carpets need cleaning do the drapes
need dusting
and for god's sake your lawn needs
mowing my guys
spring has officially sprung and the
global leaders in below the waist
grooming have the best
tools for cleaning out five
in your pants
time to clean out
time to clear it clear out your winter
book and join the other four million
men two of them are sat right here
worldwide who trust mansky we trust
manscape you should trust manscape we
should trust manscapes so what you need
to do guys is go over to manscaped.com
the code is of course sng sierra
november gold come on
um and that's going to give you 20 off
plus free shipping one more time for the
people in the back that's manscaped.com
the code is s n g sierra november golf
twenty percent off free shipping let's
get back to the episode
here we go
um anyway
um
what you got for me i have a before i've
gotten my [ __ ] but before that yeah i
want to ask you a question okay right
this is a big man question okay is it
specifically for me or is it just a
question right now it's for you
okay right now says while we're in this
room is for you okay
um
right so
if
i
you mean you were out hiking
hiking okay let's say we're out hiking
and say we take a trip to l.a
you want to go see the hollywood sign so
we take a hike up into the hills
i i um we're half an hour in
i say real quick i'm just going to take
a put piss
you pause you take in the sights
out of nowhere while you're looking out
into the horizon you hear me like ah
ah
yeah i got bit by rattlesnake on my tool
yeah i said four eggs nah you say
yeah yeah fam i just got bit by snake on
my tall i'm getting weak you look at me
i'm already looking grey
you're flailing the buckle yeah it's all
set out a buckle fan
and it's also a buckle and you can see
on the side of the tip of my dick yeah
it's just a bulging red swollen thing
with gash marks in it and i'm like no no
no no no
and let's just say before we went on
this hike yeah there was just a random
brother that said careful for
rattlesnakes you'll die you'll die in
two minutes
so this all happens i collapse
the only way to save my life i'm not
sucky at all the only way to save my
life is you suck the poison out never
you have to suck the poison out for 10
seconds
no
through hat
i'm gonna die
i'm gonna look at me man to man i'm
gonna die man to man i'm not doing it
you're gonna let me die
i'm not gonna let you die no that's what
you're saying no that's what you're
saying no what i'm saying i would suck
it myself but i can't reach
i really can't reach and there's no one
else around to suck it
i'll find someone there's no one around
if we had this is my scenario
you don't get to do this this is my
question in my scenario i've answered
your question b
you're going to let me die stay with
your chest james i will let you die
say that no no no no no no because
that's what no no you're gaslighting me
[Laughter]
so as a man you need to say right now
i'm going to let you die in this
scenario james i'm going to let you die
cool
now i've okay let's just say we've just
signed
let's just say the week but the reason
we're in l.a yeah
because we're celebrating yeah and we
just signed
a 10 million deal
with spotify mm-hmm
five mil for you five meal for me
but without me there is no deal
are you sucking my dick or not pause
yeah yeah
i let's let's say this hypothetical
scenario is real right yeah and we've
gone there spotify plural and same donny
has said be careful up there there's
snakes big man we're not going up there
but there is rattle snakes yeah but i'm
telling you brother all right if he had
pre-warned us that big man there's
rattlesnakes on this hike i'm not going
on this hike okay that's what i'm saying
okay scrap that then he didn't warn us
about the rattlesnakes no one wonders
about how would i know you're gonna die
in two minutes because we just know
because the same way you just said i'm
not sucking your dick yeah because i
knew this is where i was leading to
yeah because you knew you had to suck
the venom up
because we just know these things oh i'm
bailing i'm calling the ambulancy i'm
gonna die
i'll i will risk it we'll risk it i'll
risk it okay you've called the ambulance
you know you have to suck the poison out
and i'm you can literally see me i'm i'm
i'm close to death yeah yeah you're like
i'm gone
so regardless if we knew whatever we
knew you can see it i'm about to die
you have to suck the poison no i don't
so you're gonna throw away five mil and
your best friend i'm not sucking your
dick
say less
say less all right i'm dead then
i'm dead then
see you i want to hear you say i'll let
you die i've said it already i want to
hear you saying again i'm not saying it
again can you say it again please i've
said it already i didn't hear you say it
you heard me
you heard me
oh yeah you said in this situation
you're gonna let me die yes so now i'm
dead
so when the ambulance arrive
and they say well they're gonna ask me
why didn't you suck his dick yeah
because why would i suck his dick to
save his life oh i i know why but like
i don't understand what would the
ambulance have done
if they got them on time well that was
amazing
nobody would have had a machine to suck
it out then they should have gotten
faster or some epinephrine to stab him
they should have gotten faster
yeah but obviously
i get it but what i'm saying do you i'm
dead now
i'm dead now there's no going back
by the way don't you dare come to the
funeral
don't you
dare
because if you think in my last breath
i'm not going live on instagram
you're off your head
so if i'm suffering i'm shaking i said
please
please suck it out
and you say fam and your words are i'm
not sucking your dick yeah i said please
sure i said sure man yeah please i'm
gonna die i'm crying now cause i'm
scared i'm shaking i'm scared please
please please please please yeah i'm
i'm getting weaker by the second please
suck it out please i don't want to die
fam i don't want to die he said i'm not
sacking your dick yeah
i promise you i'll with my last straight
i'll dress my phone i'll go live on
instagram and do what and tell the world
that you're not gonna stop my day to
save my life
there will be no context to that i'll
say quickly guys because all i need is
ten seconds yeah as soon as i go live
and i see the thing spinning yeah i said
guys i just got bit by a [ __ ]
rattlesnake if your head could save my
life there's no one else here and he
refuses to stop my dicks are going to
let me die and then i'll just
that's it by the way don't you dare come
to me yes you don't even dare come to
the funeral i'm going to what do you
have to say i'm going to be at your
funeral no you're not yes who is going
to stop me you my family because they
all know the man then won't let you come
because the manner will suck my dick
okay we had this discussion online
that's why i asked you because this is
not my question okay this is jay's
question okay it doesn't put that
doesn't surprise me that definitely
doesn't surprise me and he said he'll
suck it okay and i said i'll say i'll
suck your dick
okay i would actually save your life
i mean don't get me i would save your
life i won't save your life like that
i'll save your life however i need to
save your life because you're my friend
and you're my brother and you mean the
world to me
but clearly i know how you feel about
the situation and your pride is more
important than your friendship to me
and that's fine i just wanted to hear it
from your mouth
because you know what else
jay said you wouldn't suck it and i
agreed and we knew you wouldn't suck my
dictate my life last question before we
move on yeah would you let me suck yours
or would you just die like a man i mean
i don't necessarily think i'd have a
choice it would be your choice what you
want to do
oh okay so say you got bit yeah i
understand the scenario but i don't yeah
i wouldn't have a choice i'd be weak as
[ __ ] how can i speak
so if i say do you want me to suck it
out yeah but i say yeah if i if i even
if i say no would you let me die
considering you said you won't let me
die that's beside the point i'm saying
what your will would say i would still
say no no because oh you say no don't
suck out let me die i want to say i'll
be like if
big man i'll still say no i don't know
what else i'd say but i'll say big man
or ambulance or whatever i've caught the
ambulance
let's say because i said let's say
there's 10 minutes
i called the ambulance minute one
it's gonna have to be an air ambulance
minute nine has rocked around we're
looking around i can see at least three
miles in every direction there ain't an
ambulance coming
so i say fam
you're gonna die like a minute do you
want me to suck it out
i would still say no you'll say no i
would i feel like i was still saying but
whether you do it or not is up to you
because of course i'll do it
so it doesn't change the fact where i
say no or not no i just wanted to see
where your head was at
that's mad you'd rather die than have
your homies like i didn't rather die i
wouldn't but that's what you're saying
but it's a pickup it is a pick your
poison
i wouldn't rather either yeah
but what i'm saying is would you like
verbally let cause i'm gonna because
obviously i'm gonna rape you
it's essentially
jesus i'm gonna like
i'm gonna mouth rape you i'm going to
have to to save your life
because you're going to say no don't do
it and obviously i'm going to do it
and whatever demons you have afterwards
yeah i've got a clean conscience i'm
sleeping good that night
whatever you have
is on you but i'm going to do it
and if you want to sue you can sue
what's these what's serious what are we
talking about here bro sue you know
um but yeah i'll do it all right fair
play but i just wanted to see if you
would say don't do it
and i'll say fam i don't think you
understand the severity of the situation
life
i would still say don't do it but i know
for like you already said i know you
would do it anyway oh
but that's not the reason why that's not
the reason why i say don't do it you
want to save face and live
you tricksy little kitten you want to
save face and live
that's not the reason why
my reasoning is my reasoning but like
you already said you're going to do it
so
yeah that's nuts
that's nuts that's nuts that's nice
that's nuts bro
i already knew where this was gearing
towards
that's jokes right uh you've done your
fun fact
i've got under my [ __ ]
i've got under my [ __ ] hit me oh my
god fam
i wrote this in my notes to read out oh
a few weeks ago
[Music]
and
i had forgotten what it was until now
check this out okay
speaking of consent check this out yeah
right
am i the [ __ ]
i was friends with this guy back when we
were 18.
i went to his to watch harry potter and
he started kissing me
i stopped it as we were just friends and
and i wasn't interested
he called me a tease for not sleeping
with him and proceeded to whip off all
of his clothes
and wanked off next to me what's who had
what fu had that is beyond a violation
fam
he finished
put his clothes on
and i left once the film was done
and he never spoke to me again
i would have left sooner but sorry to
stop you was she in his yard or he in i
miss well she said left so i'm assuming
she was
his yard yeah okay cool i would have
left sooner but it was my dvd
and your girl wasn't about to lose a
harry potter dvd
is he the [ __ ]
of for doing what he did of course like
it's such a crazy scenario i don't know
what she's lived through
how
wait
wait wait so they started lips in
watching harry potter right started lips
in
mid lips she pauses says stop i'm not
into this whatever let's watch the movie
let's chill let's catch this one i'm
here for he says nah he says rah you're
a teaser you're a [ __ ] tease i'm hard
as [ __ ]
backs off all his gums naked to the
gills
and bashes
finish while harry potter's still on
yeah avada kedavra or damn
yeah yeah literally yeah he's using his
tool as the as the wanted
nuts put his gums backs on
sits on the surface
i can breathe again and then they watch
the rest finish the movie and then she
dips yeah
yo i yo i wouldn't know who to speak to
after that
because no one would believe what i've
just said oh one million percent no one
would believe what i've just i couldn't
believe it when i read it
i didn't leave because i'm not about to
lose a harry potter dvd [ __ ] a dvd
another one
a dv i'm trying i could have lost my
life i don't know what he's capable of
he's a psychopath i don't know what he's
capable of bro doesn't i don't know what
she's lived through
wow i have never
unwarrantly just gotten naked in front
of my partner ever out of frustration he
got naked out of frustration just like
that and bashed to completion yo
that's
he's not there that's different that's
different bro
that's different
yo
yes he's the ass he's he's more than an
[ __ ] he's a psychopath yeah he's just
crazy he should never see him again you
should block him and everything
yeah [ __ ] your dvd and [ __ ] you that's
that's the wildest thing trust me that's
the wildest thing i don't even know why
you'd ask if he's an [ __ ]
what are you actually asking
because in what universe do we say no
he's not because you are a tease
actually
to be frank you are at ease
and he deserved whatever
he did i don't know what you call that
yeah but wow that's the weirdest king
fetish i don't even know what it is man
that's not brother
yeah yeah he doesn't experience barriers
facts he doesn't process barriers social
barriers environmental barriers he
doesn't he doesn't acknowledge them
and that's scary that is scary i i
generally fear for her oh 1 million
she stayed and watched the rest of the
thing
what was she doing while he was bashing
fam probably watching the film
impossible said i'm not going to engage
in this impossible
impossible
it's impossible for her to stay stoned
watching the tv while he was there
wanking by her ear impossible
nah he would have been
heaving oh that's nasty
stop
bro i'm not engaging
there's no way that's disgusting there's
no way she stood there
there's no way she found it there's no
way she firmed that
because i'm assuming he offered her a
drink i'm taking the glass i'm cracking
on his head
if he's any sort of gentleman he would
have offered her a drink he's not a
gentleman he's not man got stark naked
in his living room why naked and pull
the waistband down and just bashed in
front of her to completion
what's he because she's a quite unquote
tease
because we lipped and said now hold off
let me i just i just came into our chat
apart and we got lost in it i don't want
to do this
buy another dvd i don't understand what
you were doing he's going to be on the
list in a few years oh he's probably on
this now he's going to be on a list soon
that's um jesus christ that's the
wildest one one of the wildest ones
you've read to me short but sweet but
one of the wildest ones you've read to
me bro oh a million percent one one
literally
right
time for
our weekly
instagram
question answering segment
so last week guys um we asked you tell
us a secret you've never told your
partner no matter how messy
and as per guys we've got
hundreds of thousands of responses i've
waited it down to like my favorite 20
odd and we're gonna roll them off okay
all right let me just get prepared yeah
mama um
i might do one more sip sip as we do
this okay what do you want to do before
yeah oh yeah i say as before do it
before okay
i'm just scared for this good sir i
believe i'm ready to laugh
right bet so like i said
tell us a secret you've never told your
partner no matter how messy
here we go
i hate it when he tries to rub my [ __ ]
because he does it wrong it's like i'm
getting carpet burn
oh my god how do you rub it like once no
to be fair
to be fair to be fair like
that guy's uncircumcised say that again
he's uncircumcised okay
i'm uncircumcised so i know okay like
we don't need all the
gentle behavior that you might need so
if you're new in the game of clits you
only go you uh what do they say like
something there's there's a quote of
like you
in times of stress you resort to like
the
the level of your training okay
like i understand what you're trying to
say yeah he's only he's going back to
what he knows yeah yeah yeah and yeah he
knows a genital from a genital yeah he's
uncircumcised okay because obviously you
man have to treat your tool with respect
you know i mean
there's a there's a gentle kind of
finesse that you need to bash off okay
because you ain't got the support of
that skin
okay you just got raw material okay
more sensitive materials yeah yeah and
circumcised man don't have that yeah
yeah we can do we work say less okay so
yes that's
yeah i'm telling you okay okay okay okay
now is yeah the clocks are working yeah
yeah okay okay
say less
sometimes i like to cover myself in
vaseline and slide across my wooden
floor
that's [ __ ] funny
jesus
i found she cheated on me
i found out she cheated on me sorry so i
soaked her toothbrush in toilet water
before breaking up with her
it's [ __ ] disgusting
that's disgusting
i'm sleeping with his brother too
that's kind of sexy
is it crazy is that crazy for me to say
maybe i've had too much to kill her
that's kind of sexy not if it's me and
my brother
i'm looking at you i don't know if it's
me and my brother but if it's on like a
brazos thing like if
you know what i mean
if i stumbled across that yeah in a porn
story yeah
shouldn't give a single [ __ ] the
brazzer's tick
yeah yeah she didn't give a single yeah
yeah i hear that oh
he was the secret
again
sexy it is but
he doesn't know that
i just recap what the question is
and he doesn't know
fascinating bro how she's patting that
wow
oh i know that she's uh emotionally
manipulated him to that situation oh
rags
i just don't like talking on the phone
yeah
jeremy
what's what sat me when i tell you to
whatsapp yeah
it's basically what did i tell you about
speaking to me directly yeah literally
it's a sub dom yeah yeah situation oh
bless him bless him
uh i was looking at ig models on my
phone whilst i was hitting it from the
back
wow that's dark wow
i'm sorry but demand not
looking look at themselves in the mirror
after situations like that and think i
need a drastic change yeah
a drastic shock
horrible change i need a turn left
because this isn't fair to me it's not
about to hurt yep
like what are we doing yeah yeah that's
disgusting yep yep jesus christ
cracked i used to create fake ig
accounts to harass my own ig so he would
defend my honor
oh my god
crazy
crazy nah
i've never seen or read anything like
that that's crazy that's [ __ ] tapped
what are you on about
to harass my own ig so you can defend my
honor
crazy
i could never find that i'd be violent
[Laughter]
you think it's a game you said that
i'd be violent i could never find that
out yeah upon among figuring out what's
just been happening i would react
violently
physically and violently
i could never find that out wow
brother wow someone just a quick pause
someone said to me the other day i can't
remember who it was yeah someone said i
was talking about like obviously the ig
questions and the and the like
uh kind of like sng confessions and
stuff like that yeah and i was like and
they said um
i can't believe people respond to you
from their real accounts
i can't believe people confessed this
from their real account it's nuts it's
actually mad nuts but like at the same
time we have no idea who they are yeah
they might as well be anonymous because
i think just because we know what it's
anonymity anyways yeah it's synonymous
i still use facebook to remember her her
birthday we've been together eight years
oh
that's sticky that's a bit sticky but
fair
is it fair i don't think it's i'll tell
you why it's fair why because i had a
stint where this probably isn't the case
for him but um
i had a stint where one girlfriend i was
with
in the next girlfriend i was with had a
birthday the day apart okay one was the
fourth of june one was the fifth of june
oh oh and i used to consistently get
mixed up okay
so i needed facebook to tell me okay
in that certain scenario i could
understand why you'd need facebook to
tell you yeah that's something i don't
see scenario i
100 but yeah cool
i've shat in the shower more than once
that's disgusting that's vile brother
right to what end time for what reason
how do you get rid of it you just wash
it down until it turns to nothing it
must have been a runny thing
it must have been a violent runny thing
that's disgusting it is either way yo
go on
i secretly scream at her while she's
sleeping to get things off my chest
nah
wow bro
that's not a relationship that's funny
jamie
i can see it funny saying
secretly
i was caught wanking by my mother three
times in the same week no you weren't
i'm kicking you out oh 100 i'm kicking
you out the first time and we were like
son i understand this happens boys will
be boys boys boys but
yay loud not when i'm in the yard
yeah second time under the covers second
time i'm i'm but what a [ __ ] big man
we've had this discussion
we had this discussion yesterday third
time
oh i'm sending you to counselling
get your [ __ ] together you make man you
don't live here anymore i'm sending you
somewhere because because i want to walk
freely around my my own yard
yeah
the odd i paid for you want to tell me i
can't walk freely without seeing [ __ ]
loose [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yo that was funny
i'll be livid
[Laughter]
i'll be [ __ ] living oh [ __ ]
i'll be shaking the day my son has me
walking and walking
i feel bad for him yeah because i won't
say anything to him yeah yeah but he'll
just he'll lose his bone like that yeah
he'll
walk in and walk out straight back out
and then when he thinks oh that's cool
still he'll hear me kick the wall like
from distance he'll hear me boot the
wall and like all i hear is like the
[ __ ] sake man
[ __ ] sake
he's vulnerable yeah that'll put the
fear in the blood oh he's not gonna do
that again he won't come for dinner that
day yeah
he's gonna be in his room for that three
days yeah he put the fear of [ __ ] god
in him [ __ ] hell
[Laughter]
i stopped having sex with my ex because
i caught him watching [ __ ] porn in the
bathroom wow
wow
we never kink shame on sng yeah that
scenario is hilarious today that is
hilarious [ __ ] how did you how did he
let you see what pawnee was like
closing the ting brother i don't know i
cause i'm thinking any bathroom
if i'm coming in the door's locked i'm
coming in the toilet has to be facing me
the bathroom has to be on a certain side
i've been in the bath
so you might have had the ipad fixed up
on the edge of the bathroom oh my god he
was laying this side of the doors here
so she just she walked in just saw the
ipad just chilling on the phone just
chilling like that and just saw midgets
yeah yeah
wild
yeah no wonder no wonder he's the x
i know he's google logging info so i can
track his recent location stop that
wow yeah we don't
we don't play that here
stop that immediately
bro
my grandma doesn't feel safe in his car
when he offers to take her we have to
find a way out
[Music]
that just reminds me of
are you gonna hit me like my mom said
she's not
my grandma doesn't feel safe
i already know it's an interracial
relationship oh what i already know it's
an interracial relationship
my grandma doesn't feel safe
that's hilarious
[ __ ] that's hilarious
we have to find a way out
bro
bro and i'm just trying to be a gen i'm
just trying to be a nice guy you think
oh you think i want to drive your your
nan about of course i don't i'm trying
to be a nice guy
and you might have come uh you man are
conspiring against me just concocting a
plan to get out of this whole thing
couldn't believe it i could never find
that out oh i could never find stuff
like that you're all pricks yeah i
couldn't find stuff like that because
the whole family name's done i couldn't
find that
yeah
my ex-fiancee's sister's son
let me read that again yeah yeah
i read that twice before i wrote it down
yeah so
i said stop
let me like yeah i've been reading it
slowly yeah my
i'm ready go go go really really read it
my ex-fiances
sister's son
so my ex nephew in law yeah yeah okay
cool my ex-fiance sister's son
is probably mine
dot dot dot results soon come
wild
wild ah fam the thing is sometimes i can
appreciate how i might get themselves
any scenarios
but just no yeah yeah just
no it's a non-negotiable i know we don't
play these kind of games it's just it's
to what end time pull out to what end
it's just not if you're gonna bang your
fiance sister you have to pull out you
have to pull out
laughs and these are non-negotiable
anyway
yeah
times like this origin why not i do
believe
i consider myself an atheist okay yeah i
know yeah but some people need the law
they need the fear of god in them do you
understand spiritual to awaken them yeah
because you yeah yeah you don't believe
in consequences
in this life or the next
homeboy doesn't believe in consequences
yeah
that's hilarious
it's just like you you need to fear hell
oh [ __ ] me that's hilarious yeah
caught him cheating so my empty season
start again caught him cheating so i
emptied his mum's cash up and told her
she was hacked
what's she going to do with it bro
what's she got to do with it affiliated
i'm taking you all out people are evil
i'm taking you all basically what she
said you're affiliated some take you all
out wow peak bro peek
wiped his wiped his piss
hold on wiped
wiped his piss splashes off the toilet
seat with his boxes that he left on the
floor and he wore them again
that's yeah that's that's yucky that's
pig
i mean yeah it's yeah it's still his
piss but that's still peaked of course
he doesn't know this remember yeah
yeah it's true but i'm also i don't
understand is it if they dried
because in my head this sounds butters i
don't know it sounds better but in my
head if you wipe
piss with my boxers
the only way i'm wearing those boxes if
they're dry if i put the boxes on i can
feel wet i'm immediately taking them off
so they're drying if it's got dry piss
on it you can tell me like next week oh
by the way you know the boxes you were
last week i wiped your piss on them
because you keep pissing on the toilet
i was it
okay
like to me i'd be like oh
it's a bit cruel but
it doesn't bother me an understatement
yeah i mean now if you said i used your
boxes as a tampon then you wore them for
the next three days
i can't even get his words out yeah
oh i'm gonna go yeah
i might have to shake it yeah or like i
lent them to the local prostitute
and then she did like a shift yeah
wearing your boxes i'll then i'll go
back
but my own piss
yeah what's whatever
all right
told him i was going on a girls weekend
and flew to the us to [ __ ] my business
partner instead
stop
[Laughter]
stop
wow
i'm just banging
the u.s that's intercontinental
brother she's thought about this you
thought you would fly to a different
continent
to [ __ ] someone
matt she thought about how she's gonna
and all her girls are obviously in on it
of course they are they patterned it
well yeah of course he patterned it well
props
mad
i fantasize about [ __ ] his best mate
whilst i'm [ __ ] him
i'm glad that like the premise is like
something you've never told because
don't ever tell him that regardless of
how much you hate him yeah don't ever
tell him that he might he might murder
you i promise you i couldn't hear that
i found ourselves about [ __ ] foo had
while you're [ __ ] me
you don't want me to have freedom in my
life
you want me to spend the rest of my life
behind bars yeah clearly that's what you
want from me clearly yeah because yeah
yeah yeah you can never find out that's
the that's one of the worst that's top
three things you can worst things you
can say to a man
literally i can't think of many things
worse than that
when you're banging me i i i fantasize
that it's fujad
yo yeah that's that's yeah i wouldn't
know what to feel
i wouldn't know how to feel
i genuinely wouldn't know what to feel i
and thing is once she's told me that i
can't even tell you that yeah
because we can't continue being boys
yeah after i've told you yeah yeah yeah
yeah because i didn't hold resentment
until i told you yeah and then once it's
out in the air
you think you're here now
and i'll do whatever it takes to bring
[Laughter]
i'll do whatever it takes
some movie [ __ ] bro
that's hilarious
oh god
right
after four years together
my [ __ ] yearn new me so i shagged two
co-workers oh my god this is what i'm
talking about
he could never this is what i'm talking
about people play like it's just guys
fam people play they play these little
games like it's just guys bro women my
[ __ ] yearned new me yeah these are her
words brother yarn yard i read that and
i said wow
yearned four years of my [ __ ] yearned
new me that's what she wrote yearned new
me so i banged two co-workers
never i pray to god please never let me
find out
just never let it happen yeah she could
never she could never i banged two
co-workers
my [ __ ] yearned
if i was on the receiving end as a
co-worker oh i'd be turned on oh cause
i'm banging her oh
um of course i'm back you can tell me
that you banged
like larry
in the kitchen like last week i'm still
back with you
i've been in a relationship for four
four years my pussy's desperate for new
me
i'm shaking me in the in the staff room
i'm shaking oh i'm dead i'm there of
course i am that's that's too sexy
it's it's so disrespectful
depending on what side of the fence
you're on yeah yeah to be fair man don't
take it too far as well so oh it's true
yeah but they don't openly say that yeah
they don't even tell their boys that
they don't they don't even even if
they're a cheat like even if a guy's a
cheat he doesn't
boast to people yeah my dick yearns new
me so i banged two yats at work
you can't get away with that wherever
you are yeah yeah you can't
there's no etiquette around that's
that's there's no educating that yeah if
you're going to be a slight as a guider
if you're going to be a dog just do it
yeah and keep us out of it and there's
rules to it yeah yeah yeah i'll just
wait for the message and be like james i
was with you on wednesday in it so i can
say yeah of course
but i don't know what went on yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's all i know yeah
i never told him the reason we got to
know each other was because of a bet
can you imagine
can you even imagine that brother he's
that ugly to you
you're in your friendship group he's
that ugly
you are a bet
and here we are that's one of the worst
things like when you when we're the
meanest things you can say the meanest
things a woman can say to you is one
yeah one of them is
you were a bet
and now i'm stuck here
i'd need you and your friends to gather
immediately so i need to find out who
was in this bet
immediately whose idea was it i need all
of you to to form a good now yes i'm
gonna be livid
[Laughter]
i faked seizures next to him in bed so
he didn't do the nasty
faked
seizures brother
stop
that
that foamy mountain
this was a girl by the way
so he didn't bang me
up just she's just shaking in bed fake
seizures next to him does she not
understand what fear that we'll put in
him brother
fake seizures plural plural
dump me
she must have lied that she's an
epileptic or something oh 100 something
because that doesn't make sense break up
with me if that happens the first time
and we don't run hospital yeah you're a
liar yeah yeah
yeah yeah science off yeah yeah yeah
cause i'm gonna keep bringing up the
seizure today yeah and if you don't want
to keep talking about this she's gonna
finesse it like it's a photo sensitive
thing
no yeah liars brother
liars
i read i read his texts through his ipad
to make sure his family wasn't talking
[ __ ] about me
she's black 100 she's black
i can't remember but she's black 100
she's black i'm falling out of love with
him but i can't be asked to start over
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] say that sounds exactly
like one you said the other week
from a guy it's a hall of fame yeah yeah
i think i don't even like my girl but i
just come back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah is it that time is it
do you ha do we have to start again can
you just enjoy your own company
[ __ ] sake
i know he doesn't know how to wipe his
arse seeing as he always has [ __ ] in his
pants
that's one of my worst fears
for one that's why you'll never see me
buy white boxes
and for two
wash your body in it
bro my worst fear is having my wife or
whatever go through laundry and just see
[ __ ] in my boxes
that's
that's a different level of humiliation
that's a different
level of humiliation because when i push
her over the edge yeah
and she's gonna say throw that in my
face fam yeah you want to say i can't
articulate yeah big man you don't even
have to wipe your own art you'd be like
what where's that what do you mean you
will step back
what do you mean because the aura is
bigger now step back
or is bigger than yours now yeah yeah
she's commanding the room
yeah she's filled up the whole that um
what do they call it um
spiritual pressure
that spiritual pressure is elevated yes
it's hers now that nen is hers now yeah
yeah yeah yeah
what's that that
um what's the song from bleach that you
know when it's about to pop off i don't
remember um
if you wanna see some
action i don't know gotta be the center
of attraction you don't remember that no
brother bleach was a long time ago all
right fair play fair play fair play
almost like 10 years ago yeah it was the
same for you to be fair yeah
yeah i don't remember bro
yeah you don't even have to warp your
ass properly what do you mean what do i
mean
swear fam swear look at your boxes right
now the ones you got on see what's
happening no no look at them no no down
the box
i'll flip this fridge i'll flip this
[ __ ] fridge
she knows you've gone for a [ __ ] today
no pull down your boxes right [ __ ]
now and just tell me and tell me
[Laughter]
oh she's commanding the room she's
commanding the room
listen to me
ask yourself remember fix yourself
forever i'd have a panic attack
i'd have a panic attack
i can't handle that level of
confrontation
pull down your buttocks right now and
tell me you know what
i'll have to knock you out you'd have to
i'm not putting anything down
you say no
i'll do it for you she tries to go no no
no no you have to pop her nose bro
i can't laugh anymore lose an argument
that way you can't because the the
relationship can never repair itself i
can't she's
she's taking it too far and you're
always gonna remember that
regardless of whatever happy moment
you're in wow the back of your mind is
going to be there wow she's won that
argument and you can never turn take
that back wow
you've that's the most prominent point
you've ever made on this podcast
pull down your boxes right now and tell
me you know how to wipe drugs
i don't
i've never experienced anything like
that i'm not you joking i've never
experienced conversation like that
come back from that you can't come back
from that
and you'll see even if you say no no no
she's like bet i'm gonna grab one in
from a laundry basket she's gonna show
you regard i promise you i'm not
responding and i'm packing my bags and
i'm leaving
i can't take that kind of hell
that's the biggest l oh that's the word
wow wow i owe you a round of applause
for that
[ __ ] that's perspective bro
bro [ __ ]
right i've only got a few left calm
i'd sign into his friend's private ig
account to see their combos
how the [ __ ] fam that's all she wrote
and i asked the same question you're
about to ask me how the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] bro
believe it though
wow after i ate my girl out i looked in
the mirror and had a bit of [ __ ] on my
nose
that's part and parcel to be fair
i don't really have sympathy for him
if you're going to eat us
know whose arse you're eating
[ __ ] on your nose i get you're eating
[ __ ] from the back yeah that's the yeah
obviously yeah you're eating [ __ ] from
the back
like but [ __ ] i'm assuming it's a jewish
gentleman
it's not a black guy
a jewish
gentleman
i'm a schmidt
i'm assuming he's from eastern european
descent the nose is pointed because we
we we curve off
my nose ain't penetrating anyone's ass
bro i'll take that for free
bro
you're on some point that could never
happen and that's the game you decided
to play yeah because no shit's touching
my nose literally
no she's touching my nose and i'm not
eating
[ __ ] from the back
unless she just come out the shower bro
she needs to be fresh yeah fresh i'll
eat disco [ __ ]
from from a laying position
disco [ __ ]
i'll leave yeah funky fresh [ __ ]
but i
it's a calculated risk yeah i'm not if
we if i've just draws you from the from
the shrubs yeah and i'll bring you back
i'm eating your ass
i don't know you i don't know you
brother
facts
yes that's a risk he did a yeah he's not
a calculated guy and that's on him hey
this one's gonna make you gag
when he throws away the condom i go to
the bathroom search for it and lick the
sperm out
why
just why fam just
why don't you tell him to finish not in
your mouth finish in my mouth babes
please i'm yearning for it
shove it down my throat and let me
swallow what is all this licking out the
condom thing what is that
what is that i haven't got the words
what is that stuff
i haven't got the words for you
i don't have the words for you bro
because you're
denying everyone pleasure bro
you're getting second hand nut from a
nasty latex condom and he's not
finishing their mouths
that's a lose-lose it's
the words
not in my mouth
are
they what they do to the chemicals
it's it's um what's the what's it's a
commandment basically that's the word
i'm looking for it's a [ __ ]
commandment you know
any girl if you're stroking if you're
banging a girl she says finishing my
mouth not on my mouth in my mouth
i was 25 strokes away i'm now three
straight strokes away and i'm going to
i'm climbing up to you yeah you're not
in your mouth and now you're happy and
i'm happy boom
boy
if i catch you digging out condoms like
a vampire
that's i've got a street vampire
then we're done bro
so it's a lose-lose just tell me tonight
in your mouth
ah yeah
last one all right last one go on snuck
off to get a drink on a first date i
actually went for a nervous [ __ ]
yuck
yuck that was a girl by the way of
course oh oh i know it was
i'm full aware
that's disgusting
that was this week's instagram question
and answer so thank you again for the
lovely ass feedback because you guys
keep making us laugh weekly yeah man the
general public are the best community
you guys are the funniest people the
rule of thumb
[ __ ] now but yeah guys thank you very
much um
obviously guys
hop on over to patreon.com
to catch this week's thursday episode um
and as always guys level of love gang
[Music]
you